me han pedido la noción intuitiva de por
qué ha elevado a la menos ve es igual a
1 / ha elevado al ave pero antes de que
te dé esa noción intuitiva quiero que te
des cuenta de que esta es una definición
no sé quién desarrolla las matemáticas
que más bien fue un grupo de personas
que desarrolló las matemáticas una
convención que surgió establecieron esta
igualdad como una definición te va a
mostrar una de esas razones y te vas a
dar cuenta que esta es una buena
definición en el sentido de que es
consistente con otras leyes de
exponentes por ejemplo a partir de esta
ley de los exponentes negativos se puede
derivar la ley del exponente cero
tomemos entonces los exponentes
positivos creo que estos son bastante
intuitivo empezamos con
elevado a la 1a al cuadrado a al cubo ya
elevado a la cuarta potencia ha elevado
a la 1 ya sabemos que eso es
para llegar de a la 1a cuadrada
multiplicamos por el multiplicada por a
obtenemos a cuadrada y luego al
multiplicar a cuadrada ahora nuevamente
obtenemos a kubica y al multiplicar la
cúbica por a obtenemos a la cuarta o de
manera alternativa para disminuir el
exponente divides entre a o multiplicas
por 1 / a
para ir de a kubica cuadrada
multiplicamos por 1 entre a y para idea
cuadrada
a la 1 también multiplicamos por 1 entre
a usemos esta progresión para deducir
cuánto es a la 0 que es algo nada
intuitivo así que al hacer tú eres el
inventor el fundador de las matemáticas
modernas y tienes que definir cuánto es
a la 0 quizás es 75
quizás espí no lo sé tú tienes que
definir cuánto es a la 0 pero lo que
queremos es que a la 0 mantenga este
patrón que cada vez que divide entre a
el exponente disminuye en una unidad y
entonces cómo le hacemos para que a la 1
llegar aa a la 0 bueno de a la 1 que es
simplemente a hay que dividir a entre a
o como dijimos multiplicar por 1 entre a
entonces al dividir
entre a obtenemos simplemente uno esa es
la razón de la definición o la noción
intuitiva de por qué algo elevado a la
cero es igual a uno pues como vimos al
tomar ese algo y dividirlo entre sí
mismo una vez más obtienes uno
así es que esto es bastante razonable
ahora vayamos a los exponentes negativos
ahora queremos encontrar a la menos 1
al menos uno bueno seguimos el mismo
patrón de ir dividiendo entre a entonces
a la cero hay que dividirlo entre a a la
cero lo vamos a dividir entre a a la
cero dividimos entre a pero a la cero es
igual a uno entonces uno dividido entre
a es simplemente uno entre hagamos uno
más para que tengas la idea si no es que
ya tienes claro cuál es el patrón
establezcamos entonces como obtenemos a
la menos dos de nueva cuenta que
dividido entre a sería absurdo no seguir
el patrón que hemos seguido hasta
ahorita así es que a la menos uno vamos
a dividirlo entre a a la menos uno lo
vivimos entre a 1 / a / entrada esto es
igual a 1 / al cuadrado y así podríamos
continuar con este patrón hacia la
izquierda para obtener que al a menos b
es igual a 1 / al ave en fin espero que
esto te haya dado la intuición del por
qué bueno el primer misterio que surgió
aquí fue la razón del por qué a la 0 es
igual a 1 tome en cuenta que es una
definición alguien decidió que esto es
así
pero hay una razón que le da validez a
esta definición se quiere que se
mantenga este patrón y es la misma razón
del por qué los exponentes negativos se
definen de esta manera lo que es
realmente increíble es que no tan solo
se mantiene este patrón de que cuando
dividiese entre a disminuye el exponente
y cuando multiplicas por a aumentas el
exponente pero cómo basar en los demás
vídeos de leyes sobre los exponentes
todas esas leyes son consistentes con
esta definición de algo elevado a la
cero así como con esta definición de
algo elevado a una potencia negativa
espero que esto no haya sido confuso y
te haya dado la noción intuitiva para
desmitificar algo que es realmente
misterioso la primera vez que lo ves